Hi, this is Dr. Cabin-Cutters and we're going to present you with some information that
I entitled, Healey the stomach and how the cells produce hydrochloric acid.
Now I know at the outset that that sounds extremely boring and why in the world would I ever
want to know anything about that.
But trust me, it is extremely important.
In fact, one could argue that the problems with hydrochloric acid production and the stomach
flexibility to function properly could be the onset or maybe the problems with that could
be the beginning of maybe most of diseases.
So I'm trying to make this as interesting as possible, so stay with me here.
So when we talk about Healey the stomach, we have to understand some anatomy, general purpose
of the stomach and physiology of the stomach, now this picture here, not the greatest picture,
but it shows the esophagus coming into the stomach and that green part that is labeled
cardiac, it's really the cardiac portion of your stomach where the diaphragm goes over
the stomach.
So the diaphragm, think of the diaphragm as a sheet that's laid over the stomach and separates
the gut cavity from the plural cavity where your lungs are.
Now the purpose of the diaphragm is important because the diaphragm is a thin sheet of a
muscle that lies over the stomach as I said and when this diaphragm contracts that's how
you actually take a deep breath of air.
So the purpose of the diaphragm is to contract and draw air into your lungs.
Now if the esophagus is going to go through the diaphragm there obviously needs to be a hole
there and that's called the hiatus.
So the esophagus goes through this diaphragmatic hiatus, it goes into that cardiac portion of
the stomach.
Now that hiatus or that hole in the diaphragm is very muscular around there.
The purpose of that muscular addition to the diaphragm holds the stomach down in place.
So that hiatus, that muscular rig is called a sphincter and we call that the cardiac sphincter
of the diaphragm.
So that's really important because we're going to talk about that in a little bit here.
So a few things to note again is that the diaphragm covers the stomach and the diaphragm has
a hole in it called the hiatus and the anatomy of the stomach sells.
You see in a yellow piece on the picture there, those are called rougais, they have these
little pits called gastric pits and in those gastric pits are a special type of cell called
the parietal cell in the stomach and those are the cells in the stomach that make the hydrochloric
acid.
So really important information.
It's kind of a blurry picture here but this is the importance of the hiatus and the hiatus
that hole in the diaphragm that is a sphincter that holds the stomach down.
You see on the left of this picture is a normal diaphragm sheathied over the stomach.
The esophagus going through that hole in the diaphragm and you see this next picture on
the right is what's called a hiatal hernia.
This happens a lot.
If that sphincter in the stomach weakens it all because of some reasons we're going to
talk about that my stomach can actually bulge up into that above the diaphragm that's
called a hiatal going through the hole hernia so the stomach is herniated through that hiatus.
Multiple purposes for that it's very common with little kids I always tell new parents that's
good to just kind of tug down on your baby's tummy all the time because as that sphincter
made up he fully developed that baby can have a lot of little hiatal hernias in which
could cause some projectile vomit and a lot of burping up of their food when their tummy
gets all full.
So pulling down on your stomach is really important, hiatal hernias are also important as adults
because they're a common, very common issue which can actually mimic cardiac problems because
that sphincter derives that control that sphincter also go to your whole chest cavity.
And many people in the emergency room think they're having a heart attack when they actually
just have a hiatal hernia.
So as an adult you could tug down on that stomach make sure you're off of that little bowl that
sticks out below your sternum called dysphoid process slide off of that and you just pull
your tummy down.
I tend to personally have a lot of problems with hiatal hernia maybe because I'll soda pop
a jug food I ate as a child but I tend to have to pull down my stomach especially after
a big meal I just do it honestly subconsciously they don't even think about it anymore.
Important piece there, so the purpose of the stomach, so obviously the stomach makes hydrochloric
acid.
What the purpose of hydrochloric acid helps to digest your carbohydrates and your proteins and
most people don't realize HCL is a very important first line of your immune system because any
food board pathogens that go down into your gut every time you talk you're breathing things
in and when you're breathing things in you swallow your saliva, that saliva can have bacteria
and virus and all sorts of things in it every time you eat something you can have all sorts
of pathogens in there but if you have adequate HCL production it doesn't get beyond there.
So it's killed by your stomach acid so if I have a decreased stomach acid it increase
pH in my stomach well I could end up being more prone to pathogens to parasites to infections
to bacteria that could cause me sicknesses and could damage my gut wall leading to leaky gut.
So this is where you can start saying HCL yes it's important for digestion if I don't have
proper digestion that I can't get proper absorption and I have problems but maybe even more
importantly HCL is your first light of defense against those food board pathogens so it's
going to kill parasites.
So parasites that get into our body through our esophagus are killed by the HCL.
Pretty important.
Technical slide here how does your body make HCL well carbon dioxide from the blood goes
into these parietal cells so these parietal cells on the picture on the right you can see our
way down into those little crevices in that stomach wall so the little crevices have these parietal
cells carbon dioxide comes from the blood and enters into the parietal cells baking as it mixes with
water, carbonic acid, the carbonic acid that inside the parietal cells splits it into hydrogen
and by carbonate and hydrogen gets pumped inside the stomach lumen exchange system there's actually
a little exchange rate in the receptor membrane exchanges for potassium by carbonate that it gets
exchanged into the blood stream for HCL which then gets pumped into the lumen so then in the lumen
you have hydrogen and chloride and those to combine to make HCL in your stomach the bicarbonate
then helps to buffer the blood.
So important how your blood works and we'll get into that in depth here but your blood needs
to stay buffered in a pH of about 7.35 or something like that or you will literally die so this
is one of the pieces of the buffering system to keep the blood at a normal pH now if this starts to
fail and I'm making less and less HCL for some reasons we'll discuss I also lose some of my buffering
ability so that doesn't mean my blood is going to become acidic no but it does mean that my blood
blood will up-regulate other buffering systems and one of the other buffering systems to maintain proper
pH of the blood is to take calcium out of the bone so your bones act as a source of calcium to help
buffer the blood so a person that has a long-standing decrease HCL production is also susceptible to
it increase in osteoporosis over time so there's a whole all these systems have to work together
that's part of being a holistic organism there's nothing that's wasted that God created so you can see
how it all fits together in a beautiful picture so you don't have to know any of this technical stuff
but it's important to know that that HCL's produced in the bridal cells and it also helps buffer your
blood so what does it do well it helps digest your foods it helps kill pathogens you could just
remember those two pieces it's very important the other issue with HCL if you don't get food digested
it sits in your stomach longer it becomes a you know a bolus of food in your stomach and that
becomes issues as well that's really the biggest reason why a person gets refluxes that you get this
this bolus of food sitting in your stomach and a little bit of HCL that you do have produced gets kind
of pushed up into that fundus of the stomach you could easily belch up into the esophagus causing all
sorts of problems so again a decreased hydrochloric acid production just what I said food sits in the
stomach a little bit longer longer than it's supposed to you could end up getting reflux of the
little bit of hydrochloric acid you do have up into the esophagus causing irritations food also
just gets partially digested because hydrochloric acid is a big piece of that digestive process that
breaks down proteins and carbohydrates and if it only gets partially digested it ends up finally
getting shunted into the duodenum that first part of the small intestine only partially digested
and can be a big contributor just irritating just literally physically irritating the gut
causing like you got issues we'll talk more about that when we talk about gluten and other proteins
that become sensitive to the big reason that we do is because they don't get properly digested and
fully into amino acids and go into the gut as peptide pieces that become very
strong irritants of the gut membrane and of course we talked about you lose that blood
buffering system what do you do about it so there's some solutions I always put
I put most of our patients on a digestive enzyme that has HCl in it how I don't believe that's a
complete solution okay you know just okay here's the problem so this isn't really a medical
solution we're going to fix the problem by adding HCl it's a decrease HCl or a hypochloridria
so we're going to add HCl but we didn't fix the reason why so we want to address that as well
but you have to start this way because you have to get take some pressure off the stomach cells so
that they can start producing the HCl in that mechanism we talked about on a few slides back
but you have to give them a little break so you have to take a sub-sort of digestive enzyme with HCl
now these are two products that we currently use in our office and I'm not against you see
another product is well there's a lot of good products out there you can find these in our store if
you so desire we always start out just by taking wood per meal now when your substituting a supplement
for your lack of HCl and digestive enzymes need you take them with a with your food so you wouldn't
take this on an empty stomach you don't have to be food in there to digest so you want to take them
when you eat so I always tell patients that oh my gosh I forgot to take my HCl-wise iPad or my
digestimes and it's now an hour after I ate well you missed the window maybe give yourself a half
hour window after you eat you know before during or after you eat I always think it's a little bit
better before but if you missed the window a half hour after it well you missed it next time you eat
take some so should I take how many should I take that's something you have to kind of test out
everybody's a little different for myself a phyto I eat a big turkey dinner or something like that
I may take three to six side-pin just to I just need to help digest you digest this I have a
notorious issue with my stomach that goes long back because of my diet growing up but you probably
do too so you have to kind of play with the dosage to see how your symptoms are if you have reflux so
that's your major issue and your major symptoms are reflux and heartburn it could take a long time
to heal so you got to give yourself a month or two played with the dosage and I'll be the dosage
when you're eating now you could never technically really hurt yourself by taking supplements like this
unless you take them on an empty stomach and you take a lot of them you're just going to get a
stomach ache that's all you're going to get so your stomach's going to really hurt how you fix that
is just by putting something in your stomach like food and it'll solve the problem and don't do that
again so there is a day dangers there's no side effects there's no negative feedback loops
for HCL so you know the fear of if I start taking HCL the stomach will will decrease production of
HCL it doesn't work that way so that's why I wanted to show you the technical slide of how
HCL is produced if there's no negative feedback loop eating that if you have too much HCL production
your body shuts it out that's the mistobar of the ridiculousness of using thumbs and
and acid blockers like prilosec is that you are shedding off HCL productions in the mistobar
of oh I have reflux so I must have too much acid that is completely wrong there's no science that
shows that all the science shows exactly what I'm telling you but there's no drug that they make
60 billion dollars a year whatever they make on that that they're going to keep you in the dark
for so number one you substitute some HCL and enzymes number two you have to get to the cause so
yeah I was going to ask the question what why so identify what initially caused the decrease
production GMO foods a big cause of decreased HCL production artificial colorings flavorings
additives MSG fluoride chlorine huge blockages that block the production of HCL I'm not going to
get into the biochemistry of fluoride and chlorine but they're huge in this so you have to address
those situations and that's not what this slide presentation is about we'll talk about that more
this entire program but you want to look at that you want to look at different chemicals and the
effects that that has on your biochemistry of the stomach you also want to change your diet so
going to a whole food diet is super important to refer you to the to our my eating and my coveted
diet in our my whole food diet that describes this in detail and changing your diet is all important
so people that want to come to us and say I really want to get healthy but don't change anything I do
it's time just to say goodbye because it's never going to happen you keep doing the same thing and
you're going to get the same results kind of thing so in summary we just want to stop taking acid
blockers we want to solve that problem and this is it this is not just an issue with people that are
a lot of reflux that are taking tubs and things like that this is an issue with people that have leaky
gut any autoimmune issues well how do we know of leaky gut well there's a whole presentation on that as
we go so hold on but any autoimmune issues any chronic issues any chronic fatigue any disease
process at all like I said at the beginning this could start with the stomach so it would be safe
to say that probably every human being would benefit by taking an HCL and a digestive enzyme to start
in their healing process now don't don't get me wrong you don't need to take that the rest of your
life currently I take the iPad and digestimes but I literally only take them maybe you know four or
five days a month at this point in my life what I eat a big meal if I feel like it's my food
isn't be digested real well something for some reason it's just kind of city there I'll take some
side pan or digestimes so is it it's if that is a product HCL and a digestive enzyme that you really
want to have in your nutrition chest or your vitamin chest or medicine chest in your house
that you could use on a regular basis I would not suggest you use it a little children because
if the product has HCL it you can't chew it because it's going to affect your teeth so it's something
you have to swallow so there really isn't a substitute that I know of that that you could use for
little kids you can use just straight digestive enzymes which will help at least digest the food
that bolus what's in it what it's in the small intestine but it's not going to solve the stomach
if you just go into the next steps and change your diet it's the way to go okay we got a lot more to
go over in our other presentations so stay tuned we'll get into leaky gut and all the things that
decrease stomach acid can cause great I hope you learned a lot